tout d'abord bonjour à tous farid disais
que je serai le meilleur pour par la
systémique je suis patient je serai le
meilleur pour parler de systémique mais
je vous faire part plutôt de mon
expérience par rapport par rapport à
tout ça donc j'ai eu la chance j'ai un
parcours très atypique et à l'âge de 30
ans j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer sur
mon chemin sur ma route la systémique et
la thérapie brève jusqu alors j'avais
une vision assez interactionnelle des
choses j'ai une formation bts ou on a
forcément à prendre toutes en compte
pour considérer une situation un système
une entreprise et j'ai un parcours aussi
dans le sport la même façon les notions
de feedback d'apprentissage tout ça ne
m'était pas complètement inconnu et
c'est un moment où j'ai eu un gros gros
changement professionnel où je passais
du mieux d'équitation au milieu du
social de l'accompagnement social où
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
christian royer qui était lui-même
thérapeute en thérapie brève qui a été
formé ali g b de liège
l'institut grégory benson et qui
m'embauche a à ce moment là pour
travailler sur du public en grande
difficulté on va faire un petit peu
d'historique pour les gens qui auraient
un peu d'intérêt à cela les origines
donc l'institut gregory bateson de liège
c'est des chercheurs un groupe de
pionniers de la thérapie brève en europe
qui a passé l'atlantique étaient allés
se former au mental recherche institut à
palo alto
ils ont monté le l'institut grégory
benson à liège qui est avant tout un
institut pour la thérapie mais qui est
aussi un organisme qui est en
perpétuelle recherche sur le travail
justement sur les interactions le
développement personnel et la stratégie
de communication le mental reacher
s'instituer est composé de pas mal de
gens au départ ça c'est les années 50 60
certains noms qui sape qui apparaissent
à l'écran ne sont
probablement pas inconnu pour vous si ce
n'est que quelque chose qu'on entend
beaucoup actuellement qui est l'hypnose
ericksonienne ericsson faisait partie
des paires fondateur de delà de
thérapies brèves et ces gens là ont
travaillé sur chercher une nouvelle mode
de prise en charge des gens en
difficulté les années 50-60 c'est
l'émergence de la deûle à tout ce qui va
être le schéma de la communication le
traitement de l'information et ensemble
ils vont travailler sur un sur un
support que je vous propose pour la
compréhension où on partira de
l'individu les notions qui vont nous
intéresser là vont être déjà la première
chose ça va être la vision que
l'individu à lui une peine de lui même
comment il se trouve qu'elle est sa
confiance en lui
et puis la deuxième la deuxième notion
importante ça va être sa vision du monde
et à sa vision du monde c'est plus tout
ce qu'il a traversé depuis qu'il est né
que ce soit aussi bien des rencontres
qui va faire au niveau scolaire des
maladies qui vont peut-être avoir des
décès des gens qui vont aller et venir
et c'est tout cela qui va lui permettre
de constituer des filtres pour
identifier le monde dans lequel il va se
déplacer si on parle de communication
bien évidemment c'est qu'on va se
retrouver avec une autre un autre
individu en face qui est lui même va
avoir sa propre vision lui-même et sa
propre vision du monde qui dit
communication dit forcément une
information qui va être envoyée de l'un
vers l'autre et une information qui ne
sera pas forcément que verbale mais où
tout le non verbal a beaucoup plus de
place presque que le verbal à ce moment
là évidemment il va y avoir un retour ce
retour c'est le fameux feedback
vous avez certainement pu aborder sous
plein d'autres couture et ce feedback va
permettre à l'individu premier de se re
calibrer vérifier s'il a été compris ou
sinon ça n'a pas été le cas de
reformuler différemment sa communication
or ça s'est relativement simpliste et il
manque une chose à ce schéma pour pour
qu'ils aient tout son sens c'est
évidemment le cadre dans lequel cette
communication va se dérouler ça paraît
évident mais quand vous jouez à la balle
avec des amis etc on vous pique le
ballon
vous pourrez lanchais allègrement
qui sera forcément pris comme
je te reconnais capable de me voir
piquer le ballon
ah si on change de cadre et que vous me
fait ça pendant ce temps encore je ne
pense pas que ça se passe de la même
façon donc forcément le cadre à avoir
une importance énorme
donc tout cela va leur permettre à ces
chercheurs de travailler sur une façon
d'aborder les cas cliniques en ayant
dans un premier temps beaucoup de dates
ray sur quelles sont les interactions
qui vont se dérouler par rapport à la
problématique est posée c'est à dire
quels sont les individus qui rentrent en
jeu
quelles interactions ya entre eux et
comment se joue ce problème donc ce
qu'on va chercher dans un premier temps
c'est des séquences comme comme un film
et pendant qu'on va creuser et et
explorer toutes ces séquences
la chose la plus importante là dedans va
être de repérer les tentatives de
solutions que les gens ont mis en place
pour régler leurs problèmes et l'intérêt
de cette prise de cette prise en compte
comme ça des séquences et des tentatives
de solution c'est qu'à partir de là la
méthodologie va être plus participative
avec le thérapeute va avoir à
proposer un changement et ce changement
il va le proposer de façon stratégique
par rapport à ce qu'il a capté comme
information lors des premières séances
pour ramener l'individu a changé son
mode de réponse à son problème à 180°
des solutions des tentatives de
solutions qu'il avait mis en place au
départ ça peut paraître un peu flou mais
on va revenir au fur et à mesure sur ce
sur ce schéma qui est important alors
comment moi aujourd'hui j'utilise tout
ça parce que j'ai essayé de vous faire
un résumé très concis mais c'est des
années de formation ali g b aujourd'hui
moi j'utilise ce modèle sur plusieurs
dimensions j'ai d'abord un cabinet de
thérapeutes où je reçois les gens les
patients en individuel sur des
problématiques diverses qui peuvent être
aussi bien des problèmes d'addiction
dépression troubles de comportement de
choses comme cela
je suis sollicité aussi pour faire d'eux
de la supervision des équipes de
l'analyse de pratique dans lequel je
vais utiliser effectivement tous et
décodage pour permettre d'identifier les
situations
et puis dernièrement enfin dernièrement
depuis un an et demi lui je suis
référent d'une formule s'appelle a
garanti jeunes sortant de leur parler
parce que le gouvernement a pas mal
communiquer là dessus et puis il ya eu
un fait d'actualité il ya peu de temps
sur ce sur ce sujet là les garanties
jeunes c'est une mesure d'accompagnement
renforcé qui s'adresse à des jeunes de
16 à 25 ans sortis du système scolaire
sans solution d'une situation assez
précaire et le but est de les amener à
va définir un projet professionnel
la première étape dans cette prise en
charge
c'est ce qui est un peu atypique par
rapport aux habitudes d'accompagnement
c'est qu'elle réside en un mois où les
douze individus se retrouvent ensemble
en groupe avec un chef d'orchestre donc
en l'occurrence moi et là tout ce que je
vous ai expliqué avant va prendre sa
dimension c'est à dire que ce sont les
interactions qui vont se créer qui vont
exister dans ce groupe qui vont nous
permettre et permettre surtout à
l'individu d'identifier les erreurs de
dysfonctionnelle qui va commettre niveau
communication relationnelle
d'initier de nouveaux comportements de
nouvelles tentatives plus positif plus
constructive pour communiquer avec les
autres et tout ça va l'aider à prendre
confiance en lui évidemment et de plus
va régler un certain nombre de problèmes
d'ordre éducatif cognitif et finalement
le projet professionnel il va arriver un
peu en fin de chaîne c'est à dire que du
moment où l'individu va pouvoir se
construire identifier ses propres
valeurs
apprendre à communiquer différemment
avec l'autre à partir de là on va
pouvoir commencer à identifier des
domaines professionnels dans laquelle il
va pouvoir s'épanouir et qu ils
correspondront le mieux tout ça est
passionnant c'est pour ça que je fais ce
travail
mais au-delà de ça on a deux têtes
pensantes actuellement en europe qui
sont jean jacques vidal et giorgio
nardone en italie qui travaille beaucoup
ensemble qu'ils ont écrit un ouvrage
s'appelle une logique des troubles
mentaux et dans cet ouvrage il nous
propose un décodage encore plus et
fiction je trouve par rapport à la
problématique mais ça va au delà de la
problématique là dedans il développe un
concept qui s'appelle le diagnostic
opératoire systémique est stratégique ça
se veut être un peu le pendant du dsm
pour ceux qui connaissent un petit peu
en psychologie classique c'est-à-dire
comment décrypter tout ça et comment
interagir alors ce fameux dos il est
primordial
il va se faire il va se décomposer en
trois notions très très importante
la première salle est la notion de
contrôle ne sont de contrôle face à un
problème vous allez vous retrouver le
matin avec vos lacets qui casse alors
vous êtes déjà la bourre pour aller au
boulot vous allez prendre ça en main
vous allez changer de père vous avez
changé les lacets vous avez trouvé une
solution vous êtes acteur de la
résolution de ce problème là et vous en
suivez votre journée
la deuxième le deuxième dominante ça va
être
l'évitement alors bien évidemment il
vient en opposition avec le premier
c'est à dire que ouhlala ce problème je
sais pas trop comment le gérer je vais
laisser glisser et probablement qui va
se régler tout seul la troisième
dimension est un peu plus compliquée
cette momie dimension là c'est la
validation de croyance alors dans ces
domaines là
c'est pas tant la croyance en elle-même
qui va être importante pour nous à
décoder mais plutôt comment l'individu
va valider cette croyance pour prendre
un exemple très simple
mon système familial ou dans mon système
scolaire je me suis toujours 38 ans
entendu dire que j'étais un bon à rien
que j'étais incapable d'apprendre et de
ce fait bien quand je vais me retrouver
confronté à un test je vais pas me
donner les moyens je vais pas creuser et
à un moment et bien je vais forcément
échoué au moment où j'ai échoué
cqfd auto réalisatrice
cette situation fait que ça valide ma
croyance et il avait bien raison de me
dire que j'étais un bon à rien puisque
je ne suis pas capable de le faire alors
on pourra dire c'est cette croyance de
bons à rien qui qui est nocive là il
faut faut trouver une solution mais si
on garde la même croyance le même
individu peut très bien dire au
contraire je vais prouver à tout le
monde qu'ils ont tort j'aime donner les
moyens et je vais réussir donc
finalement c'est pas cette croyance
d'être incapables qui va poser problème
et puis tout ce qu'on va en faire
donc c'est bien cette notion de
validation de croyances qui va qui va
rentrer en jeu sur la construction 20
positive ou négative de l'individu alors
globalement ces trois notions là tout
autant qu'on les utilise au quotidien
une fois on va contrôler une fois on va
plutôt évité on gère tout ça avec les
croyances qui sont les nôtres quand on
s'aperçoit que nos croyances tiennent
pas bien la route
eh ben on va les faire évoluer
globalement ça fonctionne quand ça
commence à devenir dysfonctionnelle
c'est souvent qu'on en utilise une wind
et où deux de façon beaucoup plus
répétitive est importante si on les
reprend toutes les trois la première
notion du contrôle et ben en fait juge
contrôle
et puis ça ça m'échappe c'est un peu
antinomique c'est un peu paradoxal mais
en fait si on prend un exemple d'un
point de vue éducatif je veux apprendre
à mon enfant à ne pas brûler et je vais
très attentifs parce qu'il est petit va
pas forcément comprendre mais du coup je
vous interdit de mettre la main sur le
four je suis très vigilant je contrôle
la situation en permanence pour pas
qu'ils se brûle et lui-même subissons un
contrôle permanent n'aura que je sais
c'est à dire qu'avant ce casque album
lâcher la grappe pour qu'ils puissent à
l'essayer et à ce moment là qu'est ce
qui se passe
bîmes tous les coups ça marche l'enfance
brûle la mer je suis une mauvaise mère
je n'ai pas assez contrôlés mais ce
qu'elle n'a pas forcément repérer dans
ce système c'est parce que elle a fait
que trop de contrôle qui à un moment lui
a forcément échappé sur la notion
d'évitement là on va faire appel à une
donnée qui est ancestrale chez nous être
humain qui va être la peur de peur de
d'échouer de bah je vais éviter
j'ai évité alors dans certaines
situations ça va fonctionner c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui va contrôler à ma
place et puis qui va trouver la solution
finalement c'est fonctionnel
par contre du moment où je commence à
m'enfermer dans trop d'évitement il ya
un moment où bassam échappe complètement
ce n'est plus moi qui décide pour
prendre un exemple concret
ça va être par exemple les situations
d'agoraphobie je suis pas très à l'aise
dès qu'il ya un peu un groupe de trois
personnes je sais pas trop comment me
positionner et du coup bah je vais
éviter
puis j'ai vite une fois j'évite deux
fois et puis tant que possible j'évite
de plus en plus pire moment pas
finalement dans la rue il ya plein de
gens qui ben c'est tout aussi gênant et
petit à petit comme ça je me
recroqueville sur moi je ne sors plus
chez moi et donc l'évitement pousser à
terme fait qu'on a un enfermement et que
je perds complètement le contrôle de ma
vie et puis sur la 3eme notion qui est
la validation de croyance est bien plus
j'aime accroche m'accrocher à des
croyances négatives qui n'ont pas
m'aider à me construire et bien
évidemment moi je vais m'épanouir
elle me dépasse pour exemple la
maladresse on vous dit depuis tout petit
mais était maladroit regarde pas encore
échappé cette chose voilà et en vous
colle une étiquette de maladroit
moralité au moment où on va vous
demander de faire quelque chose un peu
plus délicat à dire oh là là mais non
lui fait pas faire ce truc là il est pas
mais y est maladroit et du fait d'être
maladroit si je me confronte j'y vais
comme ça un peu tremblant et vraiment je
vais le faire je vais encore raté et je
vais encore me planter donc d'un point
de vue fonctionnel
c'est vraiment le fait de s'enfermer
dans un dé fonctionnement de façon
excessif qui va poser problème
alors en tant que thérapeute c'est ces
trois notions le contrôlant excessif on
va l'amener petit à petit a lâché prise
à éviter un peu plus lévitan excessif on
va lui apprendre à reprendre un peu le
contrôle de tout ça et puis pour ce qui
est des validations de croyance c'est
pas tout à fait la même mécanique à
accompagner dans le sens il va falloir
casser petit à petit ses valises et ses
croyances pour permettre à un individu
d'en bâtir de nouvelles beaucoup plus
fonctionnel quel lien avec demain si à
la base cette méthodologie a été pensé
pour traiter des problèmes
psychiatriques psychologiques
en fait on s'aperçoit qu'elle a beaucoup
plus de 2 détendue au niveau des
implications puisqu'on va la retrouver
au niveau des entreprises on va la
retrouver au niveau du sport on va la
retrouver à plein de niveaux
c'est dans l'interaction que tout autant
qu'on est on apprend à ce calibre et
l'homme ne sait ne peut pas ce calibre
et si les ports en interaction avec ses
semblables
et puis la vie en général de toute façon
c'est un an chez votre manque
d'interaction multiples on peut pas
décider d'un système et tout fonctionne
avec et notamment vous connaissez tous
le l'effet papillon c'est exactement
représentatif de ce fonctionnement là
moi j'observe de plus en plus des gens
qui vont rechercher à prendre en
globalité des situations et pas
forcément que des problématiques mais la
gestion d'une entreprise ou d'une équipe
en global et on va s'apercevoir que tout
ça va de plus en plus tout seul quand on
est on est dans une situation on essaie
de traiter les choses de plus en plus
vite
on a besoin déficience d'efficacité et
on en est à rechercher une mode de
pensée écologique en manque de pensée
écologique pour faire un clin d'oeil à
l'agronomie
mais en attendant c'est une réalité
telle que l'avait décrite batson batson
qui était anthropologue et un des pères
fondateurs de la thérapie brève et toute
cette recherche l'a et plus sur
l'efficacité de la compréhension de la
communication des systèmes une
efficience de tout ça on est bien dans
ce fonctionnement là haut niveau au
niveau des gens qui pensent à tout ça
actuellement nous avons ben pierre rabhi
marc vella et tous ces gens là sont dans
l'esprit général
moi ce que j'observe c'est qu'on est une
révolution de terrain réel qui
s'opposent aux révolutions qui sont qui
sont passés dans la dans toute
l'histoire de l'humanité ou qui sont
récupérés pour la plupart du temps par
des mines courants politiques religieux
et tout ça n'est pas du tout cette
révolution qui vient du terrain internet
tout ça nous permet de communiquer
beaucoup plus et ce que je vois c'est
qu'on a une montée en puissance de ça je
voudrais finir par une citation de de
kennedy ne vous demandez pas ce que
votre pays peut faire pour vous mais
demandez vous ce que vous pouvez faire
pour votre pays
moi personnellement je
tout ça dans ma vie tous les jours de
façon professionnelle comme personnelle
et vous
[Applaudissements]